- Hello, darling, hi.
- I dunno, this looks like
I'm talking to Preditor.
(upbeat funk music)
I think we communicate very well.
- Oh.
- Awesome?
- Total,
excellent communication
- 100%
- That wasn't a real sentence.
- We're like best friends,
and we always know what each
other's thinking and stuff.
- I can just look into her eyes and...
Sandwiches.
- And I know
what he's thinking, I know what he...
Yeah, it's not.
- No?
- I think I'm gonna do better.
I'm sorry, but...
- What?
- I'm gonna be honest,
I'm gonna drool a lot.
I'm gonna drool so much,
it's gonna be drool city.
- You just drooled in
your sleep last night.
- Don't tell people that!
- This looks like you're
at a dentist office.
Alright.
Hello.
- How very stylish.
- I just don't like to drool.
(sucking at spit)
I didn't mean to drool.
- Ewe.
Ewe.
- No, ewe, get it away.
- Oh, I did it!
- Oh.
(laughing)
- Drool protection engaged.
- Playful nose boop. (laughing)
- What?
- What a crafty fi-er.
- What a crafty...
- Fi-er.
- Sir.
- Sh-hiver.
- Flozzle.
- Laddle?
Low-el doodle total waverick.
- What?
- Layful nose oo!
(laughing together)
- It is an F.
- A foo-er.
- No, a hi-er, oh my God.
- Ladle, latel, okay.
- No, no.
- Like, oh, I'm not telling the truth.
I'm a hi-in.
- Lazzo doo doo total latchrick?
- I need a towel.
- Playful nose...
- Oo!
(laughing)
- Lying, like hi-ing.
- Like fibbing?
- Yes!
- Fibber!
Fibber.
- What a crafty fibber.
- Hoo, got it.
- We're hestooned up the wazoo.
We're hestooned ut the wazoo.
- Somebody steamed up the wazoo.
- No-ody huts harry, very.
- My dih-el dog, dob...
Ke-hers ter-hect teanuts.
- Oh, God.
- Hair, hair, harry...
(Amanda groaning and Raphaelle laughing)
- Erry on seed dial!
- Hestooned.
- Bestine?
- What's a bastine?
- My biffle dog.
- No.
- Oh, God, drool.
(Raphaelle laughing)
- My Biffle Bob prefers perfects peanuts.
- Yes.
- Weird.
- Ask questions efore rying...
- Ask questions before lying.
- No.
- Arriage ows are requently roken.
- Marriage vowes are secretly broken.
- Oh no, it's even worse than that.
- Skine-y...
- Tiny.
- Swiney.
- I'll give you some money. (laughing)
- Oh, buying, buying.
- Hre-quently.
- Frequently.
- Yeah, doing it a lot.
- Her-simmin, her-simmons?
- Like I promise to always
support you, and now...
- Spiny.
- Yes
- We planted spiny swine.
- Chrysanthemums.
- Kris-simmons.
(laughing)
- Marriage vows are frequently broken.
- Ye, ye, ye.
Yes, that is correct.
- This was a lot harder than I expected.
- I feel like we did okay.
- I feel like we crushed it.
- I mean, yeah.
- I wasn't expecting to drool,
and have my lips chapped at the same time.
(slurping)
- You come her often?
(laughing)
- Yeah. (laughs)